LED POI come in so many different
varieties shapes and styles these days
so how do you know which ones are best
for you Drex here from drexfactor POI
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arch to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to take
a look at what criteria you should have
in mind before purchasing a set of LED
POI but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links that
I have down in the description of this
video and special thanks to the
non-business Friends of the channel Lane
machinsky and Becca becklenen thank you
both so much for supporting my channel
my work and my mission
so we kind of have an embarrassment of
riches at this point as POI Spinners I
remember when I first started off there
was maybe one two companies Max that
actually sold LED POI and now I know of
at least a dozen different ones but with
more options also comes more choices and
with more choices well comes a lot more
confusion so I'm going to try and help
simplify things here by talking about
some criteria that I use when I look at
LED POI to see if maybe they'll be of
help to you all out there too and right
quick before we dive in if you're not
already please make sure to subscribe to
the channel I upload regular videos on
POI spinning and flow Arts so make sure
that you get to catch each and every one
so the first thing that I usually think
about when I'm evaluating instead of LED
POI is the form factor that is what
shape do they have and what is that
shape good for and what is it not so
good for most LED POI come in a form
factor wherein they're packing the LEDs
down into the end of the POI head
examples of this include things like pod
POI and all the different forms of LED
contact POI out there as well as
entry-level POI such as spin balls these
types of poi tend to be really flexible
and good for a variety of different
styles but if you're more specifically
interested in contact POI you're going
to want to find a set that have those
spherical heads because without those
you're not going to get clean contact
rolls at the other end of the spectrum
our LED POI that have a rod shaped form
factor in some cases this is done
deliberately to evoke the form factor of
glow sticks such as people that are
trying to emulate a glow stringing style
in other cases those rods host a strip
of LEDs that can be programmed to
display different images or messages
either way the weight distribution in
this form factor differs substantially
from the first type in some cases this
can make stalls a little bit more
difficult to do and in other cases it
can restrict the vocabulary of movement
to the POI to only the most basic of poi
tricks unless you know for certain that
you want to spin with a style associated
with this form factor this might not be
the one to start with there's also a
subset of poi that kind of fit into our
first form factor that seek to
illuminate the tether of the POI by
placing them inside of socks there's
only a small handful of companies out
there that offer this option and the
results are very very eye-catching the
downside is this can also restrict the
vocabulary of tricks that you can use
that said sometimes it's a trade-off
that's worth it and speaking of tethers
we do have to talk about how those
tethers influence all POI including LED
POI a lot of entry-level LED POI use
nylon strings to connect together the
heads and the handles these nylon
strings can be good as a cost saving
measure but at the same time when you're
in the initial stages of learning how to
spin and building up the calluses on
your fingers they can also very easily
strip off those calluses or irritate
your fingers in other ways many other
LED POI options use a variety of
different kinds of ropes to connect
their heads with their handles options
here include everything from Smithy rope
to static rope and a variety of
different thicknesses everything from
six millimeter all the way up to three
quarter inch and even half inch tethers
by and large if you're just starting off
any rope between six millimeters and
three quarter inch should do the trick
for you if you're interested in learning
more juggling style POI consider looking
into static ropes as an option too and
next up we have battery life battery
life matters a lot for keeping your POI
going for as long as you are in some
cases I've seen POI that can go an
entire night or longer and in some cases
I've seen POI that will conk out after
only an hour or two it can be helpful in
this case to think about what uses you
have in mind for your POI before you
purchase them is this a set of poi that
you're going to be going out jamming
with for hours on end or is it a set of
poi that you're only going to need to
use for just a few minutes when you get
on stage shorter battery life is totally
fine if you just happen to be using them
for shorter performances if you want
them to last the whole night though you
might want to look for something with
better performance and of course the
flip side and usually the trade-off with
battery life is brightness it used to be
that all LED POI were comparatively dim
and really could only be seen well in
very low light but in recent years we've
had a variety of different options
becoming available that can increase the
brightness of poi all the way from being
extremely visible to painfully visible
at night and do bear in mind that the
brighter a set of poi you're working
with almost inevitably the shorter their
battery life is going to be if this is a
set of poi that's going to be used for
performance purposes brighter is usually
better if on the other hand they're just
for casual spinning they don't need to
perhaps be as bright and also bear in
mind that many different sets of LED POI
out there now allow you to control the
brightness of the prop and of course
there's also the question of durability
the first sets of LED POI that I ever
own were incredibly fragile and would
usually break down after a couple months
worth of use but nowadays I've had led
POI that have lasted me for over a
decade and they're still kicking it for
the most part LED POI have come a long
way in the past two decades and are now
able to handle quite a lot of abuse the
one exception to this would be
programmable POI which just because of
the form factor are inherently more
delicate whenever those POI hits
something regardless of how soft it is
it bends the circuit boards inside just
a little bit and that can gradually
loosen or even break the contacts inside
over time if you're super interested in
getting programmable POI just bear in
mind that you run a high risk of them
braking and generally speaking you're
going to have to send them back into the
manufacturer to get them repaired these
are usually POI that are better just for
special events or gigs and tend not to
get a lot of use outside of those next
up a thing that I have a complicated
relationship with and that is modes most
LED POI will give you the basic option
of flashing up individual colors in a
variety of different strobe patterns or
fading between a few different colors
some have more comprehensive
capabilities and create a variety of
different patterns within their trails
in general I find that the more modes a
particular set of LED POI offers the
more difficult they are to use and
navigate your mileage may vary here but
I personally like to just put on a mode
code and go flow with them at the same
time there's a bunch of people out there
that are super into exploring different
modes and that is also a perfectly valid
Choice one thing to bear in mind here
though is that a lot of the intellectual
property around LED POI comes down to
not the hardware but the software that
is run on them so when it comes to
programming the different modes on
different POI you're almost certainly
going to have to learn a new system with
each individual company's POI that you
happen to pick up and of course in the
most advanced cases of poi modes we have
those programmable POI once again now
there's a huge difference in the
experience of setting up programmable
versus non-programmable POI with
non-programmable POI you have the modes
on the device and that's pretty much
what you're limited to with programmable
POI you can download images or type out
messages and get those POI to flash
those things as you're spending them
with programmable POI you have to think
about not just all the variables that
we've already talked about but also what
the interface is for actually
programming them which is almost always
going to happen on a laptop there's a
wide range of different options here
with some companies offering easier to
use programs and some with programs that
are a little bit less easy to use it's a
good idea to do some homework here and
figure out exactly how easy or difficult
it's going to be to get all those cool
pictures to come out of your set of poi
so these are what I tend to keep in mind
when thinking about Led POI and whether
I want to acquire some what are some
criteria that you use please leave me a
comment and let me know did you get
anything out of this video make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it to help keep the
conversation going and of course to help
my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
the support of all of these wonderful
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you so very much for your very very
generous support if you out there
watching would like to support my work
and are not currently a supporter the
way you can do that is head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you're interested
in checking out my reviews of specific
models of LED POI I'm going to go ahead
and include a link to a playlist for
those videos down in the description as
well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks based upon your past
viewing habits that you might like this
top video here so maybe give that a look
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon
peace